bonjour à tous puisque c'est les fêtes
de fin d'année j'ai décidé de vous
parler d'un sujet festif le champagne
alors vous avez déjà fait la
physico-chimie du pastis l'été dernier
donc ça se complètent pas mal
aujourd'hui on va se demander d'où
viennent les bulles du champagne comment
elles se forment et puis si ça a
vraiment un lien avec sa qualité
quand la science la première chose qu'on
peut se demander c'est les bulles du
champagne c'est des bulles de quoi alors
c'est évidemment un gaz et plus
précisément c'est du gaz carbonique du
co2 oui oui c'est le même co2 dont on
avait parlé la dernière fois et qui
réchauffe la planète
sauf que rassurez vous dans une
bouteille de champagne il n'y a que
quelques grammes de co2 et donc c'est
pas en buvant du champagne qu'on va
réchauffer le climat
enfin faudrait vraiment en bois rebond
alors ce co2 évidemment il n'est pas
présent initialement dans le jus de
raisin qu'on utilise pour faire le
champagne et il est le résultat d'une
étape vraiment spécifique de la méthode
champenoise de vinification qu'on
appelle la seconde fermentation
en fait après la première fermentation
du vin au moment où on s'apprête à
mettre le champagne dans les bouteilles
on lui ajoute un liquide qu'on appelle
la liqueur de tirage et qui contient
entre autres du sucre et des levures et
pendant le vieillissement du vin il se
produit une réaction chimique lente au
cours de laquelle les levures vont
fermenter le sucre en alcool tout en
produisant au passage du co2 et comme
cette opération elle a lieu dans la
bouteille fermé et ben le co2 qui
s'accumulent dans la bouteille
sauf que quand on regarde une bouteille
de champagne avant de l'ouvrir
y a pas de bulle dedans donc le co2 il
est où
et ben en fait il est à deux endroits il
est en partie sous forme gazeuse dans
l'espace libre qui est situé au niveau
du boulot et il est en parti dissous
dans le liquide le co2 qui est situé son
boulot c'est évidemment lui qui cause la
pression dans la bouteille et qui fait
sauter le bouchon au moment où on ouvre
et à cet endroit il peut régner une
pression d'environ 6 bar le co2 qui est
dissout dans le liquide s'est un petit
peu plus difficile de se représenter de
quoi il s'agit en fait il faut
s'imaginer des molécules de co2 qui se
promènerait librement dans le liquide
assez isolées les unes des autres et il
faut voir contre le co2 qui est dissout
et le co2 qui est sous forme gazeuse
il existe une relation d' équilibre et
ça ça se traduit par le fait que la
pression et la concentration de co2 sont
proportionnelles cette relation de
proportionnalité entre la pression dans
le boulot et le co2 dissous dans le
liquide
on l'appelle la loi de henry et en fait
elle est pas du tout spécifique du co2
et du champagne
elle vaut pour les gaz dissous en
général mais dans le cas spécifique du
champagne la constante de
proportionnalité c'est à peu près 2
grammes par litre par bach
ça veut dire que pour six bars de
pression dans le boulot la concentration
de co2 dissous dans le champagne c'est à
peu près 12 grammes par litre maintenant
qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous ouvrez
votre bouteille de champagne
et bien tout le co2 qui était accumulée
dans le goulot il va s'en aller très
rapidement et donc la pression a chuté
brutalement
du point de vue de la pression totale on
passe de six bars à un bar à peu près la
pression atmosphérique
mais en fait dans la loi de henry ce qui
compte c'est la pression qui est
spécifiquement exercée par le co2
et comme il n'y a presque pas de co2
dans l'atmosphère est bien la pression
de co2 c'est essentiellement 0 vous
voyez que du point de vue de la loi de
henry si la pression chute à 0 et ben la
concentration de co2 dissous dans le
liquide vu qu'elle est proportionnel
elle devrait aussi chuté à 0
ça veut dire que tout ce co2 dissous
dans le champagne eh ben il doit
s'échapper et se barrer sous forme
gazeuse
ce passage de forme 10 août à forme
gazeuse c'est ce qu'on appelle un
changement d'état c'est un peu
comparable par exemple à l'ébullition de
l'eau ou alors à la congélation le
changement de l'eau liquide en glace
c'est aussi un changement d'état et il
ya un truc important à savoir sur les
changements d'état c'est qu'ils sont pas
automatiques
c'est pas parce que les conditions sont
réunies pour qu'un changement d'état se
produisent qui va se produire tout de
suite
l'exemple le plus connu c'est ce qu'on
appelle la surfusion de l'eau c'est un
phénomène assez spectaculaire qui fait
qu'on peut refroidir de l'eau liquide en
dessous de zéro sans quelques on gèle
tout de suite
en fait si on la refroidit vraiment très
précautionneusement elle peut rester
liquide même si on va je sais pas - 10°
et c'est seulement si il ya un choc ou
alors une poussière qui va perturber
cette optique que la cristallisation en
glace peut s'initier
la surfusion de l'eau c'est une manie
vraiment sympa que j'aurais aimé vous
faire en fait à chaque fois que j'essaie
de la faire ça rate donc peut-être pour
une prochaine fois
en tout cas pour le co2 qui est dissout
dans le champagne
il se passe exactement la même chose que
pour l'eau en surfusion c'est à dire que
en principe il devrait changer d'état et
donc il devrait se transformer sous
forme gazeuse mais pour que ça se fasse
en pratique il faut que quelque chose me
pousse il faut un événement déclencheur
et le mieux c'est d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle un site de nucléation c'est à
dire un endroit où ce changement va
pouvoir s'effectuer
d'ailleurs quand on regarde une flûte de
champagne on voit comme des séries de
bulles qui monte en colonne l'art en
petit train et ça laisse bien pensé qu'à
la base de la colonne
il y a un truc spécial qui fait que les
bulles secret dans des sites spécifiques
une manière simple d'avoir un site de
nucléation c'est d'avoir une petite
poche de gaz s'est d'ailleurs pendant un
moment on a pensé que les aspérités
naturelles du verre elle pouvait
emprisonné un petit peu d'air au moment
où on faisait le service gilles
champagne et servir ensuite de cible de
nucléation d'ailleurs un truc qui marche
bien c'est de s'amuser à graver
l'intérieur d'un verre parce que les
gravures
elles vont pouvoir emprisonner un petit
peu d'air et servir de cible de
nucléation pour les pulls
bon mais pour que ça fonctionne bien en
fait il faut graver assez fort et on a
compris depuis que les aspérités
naturelles du verre en fait elle était
trop petite pour servir de site de
nucléation et donc être à l'origine du
phénomène
c'est que l'explication elle est
ailleurs alors pour trouver la source
des bulles du champagne
gérard liger-belair qui dirige à
l'université de reims une petite équipe
de recherche consacrés au champagne a dû
faire des observations très précises il
a placé un verre de champagne près d'une
caméra avec un microscope et il a pu
identifier le coupable
le coupable c'est pas les aspérités du
verre ce sont des petits bouts de fibres
de cellulose tel qu'on en trouve en fait
un peu partout autour de nous et
notamment dans les verres et ses petites
fibres de cellulose
elles vont servir de véritable usine à
bulles selon un mécanisme qui est assez
amusant
en fait une fibre elle peut emprisonner
une toute petite poche d'air dans sa
structure qui va rester au moment où on
sert le champagne
et quand le co2 qui est dissout dans le
vin se trouvent en contact avec cette
petite poche d'air ils commencent à
migrer et vient faire grossir la poche
et quand elle a suffisamment grossit en
fait sous l'effet de la poussée
d'archimède elle s'arrache de la fibre
et elle monte dans le vert et là le
miracle qui se produit c'est qu'un petit
bout de la bulle reste toujours coincés
prisonniers dans la fibre et peut
resservir pour recommencer le cycle de
bulles âge et c'est pour ça qu'on voit
toujours des colonnes de bulles qui
monte du même endroit en fait
certainement qu'à la base de chaque
colonne il ya une petite fille de
cellulose ses films de cellulose en fait
elles peuvent provenir par exemple de
nouveaux vêtements
et donc si vous voulez des belles bulles
dans vos verres de champagne le meilleur
moyen c'est de laver les verts à la main
et de les essuyer avec un chiffon est
comme ça vous allez laisser la surface
du verre tout un tas de films de
cellulose qui vont servir d' usine à
bulle une fois que vous aurez versé
votre champagne
alors maintenant on va en revenir à la
question qui intéresse plein de monde
quel lien il ya entre les bulles du
champagne et sa qualité
alors la première chose qu'il faut dire
c'est que les bulles elles jouent un
rôle essentiel dans la dégustation en
fait quand elle remonte dans le vert à
l'interface entre les bulles et le
champagne
il ya tout un tas de molécules
aromatiques qui viennent se mettre et
ces molécules aromatiques elles sont
dispersées dans votre bouche au moment
où vous buvez le champagne donc les
bulles elles servent en quelque sorte d'
exhausteurs de goût mais l'affirmation
qu'on entend le plus souvent c'est que
des bulles plus fines seraient le signe
d'un champagne de meilleure qualité
alors c'est vrai ça mais en fait non pas
vraiment en fait la taille des bulles
elle dépend essentiellement de seulement
deux facteurs la hauteur du verre et la
quantité de co2 dissous dans le vin la
hauteur du verre c'est parce que quand
une bulle remonte le long du verre elle
grossit elles se chargent de co2 donc
plus le verre sera au plus la bulle sera
grosse à la fin donc avec le même
champagne si vous me servez dans une
coupe dorée début le plus fine que si
vous servez dans une flûte
l'autre facteur qui joue c'est le taux
de co2 dissoudront champagne plus il est
important plus les vul grossiront vite
donc un champagne qui est un peu éventé
il aura naturellement des bulles plus
fine mais c'est aussi le cas d'un
champagne plus vieux parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'au cours de son vieillissement
le champagne perd un petit peu de co2
par le bouchon il perd environ 1 gramme
par litre tous les deux ans est donc un
champagne pluvieux aura naturellement
des bulles plus fine
vous voyez qu'il ya pas de lien
fondamental entre la taille des bulles
et la qualité du champagne
à la limite la seule chose qui peut y
avoir c'est une espèce de corrélation
apparente qui est lié au fait que les
champagne qu'on va boire vieux et donc
qu'ils vont naturellement avoir des plus
fines
c'est en général les champagnes de
meilleure qualité c'est certainement ça
d'ailleurs qui est à l'origine de la
légende mais c'est pas une relation de
cause à effet pour ceux qui ont vu ma
vidéo sur le paradoxe de simpson c'est
un bel exemple l'âge du vin joue le rôle
de facteur de confusion
enfin dans tous les cas vous prenez pas
la tête avec la taille des bulles et
profitez bien de votre dégustation
voilà je vous souhaite de passer
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
amusez vous bien à faire de la science à
table ou à la mairie
n'oubliez pas de partager cette vidéo
avec votre famille ou vos amis
et puis on se retrouve l'année prochaine
pour de nouvelles vidéos merci à bientôt